- Nico!
- Selma!
- Du willst wohl heute Abend feiern?
- Ja, na ja. Yara besteht darauf,
dass Pepe, sie und ich
auf unseren neuen
Lebensabschnitt anstoßen.
- Neuen Lebensabschnitt?
- Na ja, weil wir alle
in Deutschland bleiben
und ich hoffentlich bald in Yaras
Laden anfange zu arbeiten …
- Das ist toll, Nico. Wirklich.
- Ich hätte gerade eben fast den Sekt
und den Wein nicht bekommen.
- Die Verkäuferin wollte mir die
Flaschen nicht verkaufen,
zumindest nicht ohne Personalausweis.
- Hat sie dir nicht geglaubt,
dass du volljährig bist?
- Mal ganz ehrlich:
Sehe ich aus wie siebzehn?
- Es ist ein Kompliment,dass die Verkäu-
ferin dich nach deinem Ausweis gefragt hat.
Du siehst eben jünger aus, als du bist.
- Danke …
- Das war ein schöner Abend gestern …
- Ja, das fand ich auch.
- Ich vermisse dich, Nico …
- Dann treffen wir uns morgen!
Nur kurz.
Egal wie, aber ich muss dich sehen.
- Ich schreibe dir!